[Musique]
nathalie et limaces la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'éducation prioritaire s'est
rendu au collège bourbon à saint denis
un établissement classé en ré plus
réseau d'éducation prioritaire plus la
secrétaire d'état a pu échanger avec les
élèves et les enseignants afin
d'observer les actions d'éducation mis
en place pour réduire les inégalités
l'échec scolaire on va aller regarder
tout au long de cette journée et puis
demain les dispositifs d'éducation
prioritaire dans nos collèges dans nos
écoles à la rencontre aussi des parents
pour pour voir comment tout cela
fonctionne et éventuellement ce qu'il
faudrait encore améliorée parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'ambitions vraiment pour la
réunion pour les réunionnais et pour nos
élèves après saint denis la secrétaire
d'état s'est rendu à saint benoît au
sein du collège guy-môquet un
établissement tête de file de la cité
éducative de la commune un outil qui
vise à mettre en réseau tous les acteurs
du monde éducatif du cactus et de broc
pop au projet pour les élèves pour la
cité tout ce qu'il ya autour c'est aussi
un maillage entre le monde économique le
monde culturel le monde associative et
c'est un hymne expérience que le
département souhaite reproduire dans une
optique de société inclusive avec les
élèves qui au travers de son quartier
puissent aussi mené des actions
parallèles à l'échelle d'un territoire
en tout cas ça fait vraiment tout son
sens puisque on installe un écosystème
où on met en place autour de la table
tous les acteurs pour travailler tous
ensemble dans l'intérêt des jeunes des
élèves des jeunes et des jeunes adultes
sur le territoire
nathalie et limaces s'est également
déplacé dans le sud du département au
collège plateau goyaves j'organise très
prochainement un séminaire rêve plus et
j'aurais vraiment à coeur par exemple de
valoriser l'équipe réunionnaise qui met
beaucoup de beau disposer la secrétaire
d'état s'est ensuite rendu au collège
titan au port au coeur de la cité
éducative de la ville
[Musique]
moment au coeur
je vous aime
m
moi
ça fait
et
je vous en remercie
la réunion compte 24 collèges et 139
écoles en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
et 21 collèges et 148 écoles en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire plus
[Musique]